what's going on everybody welcome back
to my youtube channel richard on data
now if this is your first time here my
name is richard and this is the channel
where we talk about all things data
data science statistics and programming
so subscribe for all kinds of content
just like this if you haven't already
and hit the notification bell so youtube
notifies you whenever i upload a video
so i stumbled across this last week the
winners of the second annual shiny
contest
so basically our studio does this
contest every year
they'll ask people to submit some really
good inventive shiny apps
and then employees from our studio at
least i'm guessing that's how this works
they will vote on the best apps and so
this is a pretty fun thing to step
through
those of you who've been following my
channel for a little while probably know
that i'm a huge fan of r
shiny i just think it's an incredibly
flexible and powerful tool
and just really something that's good
for delivering a lot of value to a
client
uh so i thought something like this with
some really cool
shiny apps from obviously people who are
really skilled developers
i thought looking at these apps as well
as what kinds of packages they're using
i thought this would be a lot of fun
it'd be really an educational experience
as far as just demonstrating everything
shiny is capable of
and then it's helpful too to see what
packages are being used because
at the end of the day the functions from
those packages are really the building
blocks for
for these apps so we're going to go
through these apps and a little bit of
the github repositories from them
before we do that some usual asks that i
have
if you haven't already smash the like
button to this video because that really
does help my content reach a larger
audience
also i will have a link to my patreon
account in the description of this video
so if you guys are willing to support me
that way that would be
massively massively appreciated and
obviously the link to
this page as well as basically
everything that i'm showing in this
video whether it's all of these apps as
well as the github repos that i'm
looking at
all those links are going to be in the
description as well so we're going to
start from the bottom here
meaning the first app that we're going
to look at is number five on this list
and we're going to make our way all the
way up to number one
now there are also some runners up that
they mention here
these are obviously honorable mention
type things
and i guess it won't come as a surprise
to anybody
that there's a lot of apps that are
being done right now on the current
pandemic that's
making its way across the world so check
all these out too
because they're uh quite impressive in
their own right
but without further ado let's start with
number five which is this app called hex
make
so the idea here is making your own
customizable hex sticker
those of you who've been following our
studio for a while are familiar with
these things
a lot of the really big r packages have
their own hex sticker
so we can customize and make our own so
we've got this drop down menu type thing
on the left side which allows us to
customize various things
starting with managing the name maybe i
want to make one for my own youtube
channel
so we call that richard on data
and it's a little big so let's make that
a little bit smaller
maybe the size six now still a little
bit too big maybe 5.5
yeah so you get the idea you can do that
kind of thing
managing the image so the default image
on here
is that uh the devil horns fist thing
like this i feel like there's a name for
that uh and the name for it completely
escapes me at this moment
so if anybody actually knows what this
thing is called leave that in the
in the comments but uh naturally you can
change the
position for that move it up down to the
left whatever you want to do
upload your own custom image and then
naturally you can manage the hexagon as
well
so maybe change the color of it
i like the color green that looks pretty
good
so you get the idea now if we go to the
github repository
the shiny developer here his name is
colin fay
uh this app was created in what's called
a docker environment
uh based on the fact that there's this
docker file thing here that's what that
looks like to me
then if we go to the description here
that's where he details the
packages that were used to construct
this shiny obviously the first one that
gets imported
hex sticker is a package that i'm
assuming was a key
uh component of doing this and also
gollum
so when i was putting this together for
this video this is actually a really
interesting one
that i was not aware of existed
so if we do a little google search for
that the gollum r
package the cran vignette
pops up pretty quickly and
this is actually a pretty good vignette
it's pretty nicely detailed
and the idea here is the golem package
is just a kind of an
add-on to shiny that will allow you to
make nice
uh production-worthy shiny apps as well
as just
make all of the components of the shiny
app really nice and standardized
so within file new project in rstudio
you'll be able to select package for
shiny app using gollum
and it'll standardize things for you so
that you've got this app config
app server app ui all those sorts of
default files for you so everything is
in one
nice consistent uh naming convention
scheme
and then also what i thought was pretty
interesting is that a golem app
is its own package so really cool stuff
uh definitely worth checking out i think
moving on to app
number four this next one is called
datify
and this one is all about music so
specifically the kind of information
they're looking at here
is what's called valance and energy now
valance is a measure
that describes the musical positiveness
tracks with high balance
sound more positive while tracks with
low valence sound more negative
and energy uh represents a perceptual
measure of intensity and activity
uh so we have to select a couple artists
here
so one of my personal favorite bands of
all time is modest mouse
i'm gonna select them and
we add them
uh it's a little slow i think there's a
little lag there until uh
yeah there we go that gets added in now
a few of you have pointed out in my
julia video that i wear
a shirt of the band dance gavin bands so
i'm gonna throw them in here too
search them this is all pulling from
spotify we'll add them in here
and then what it's going to do is is
it's going to populate a comparison
between them
so there's a bit of information that's
provided on the two
modest mouse is mostly characterized as
alternative rock indie pop and indie
rock
dance gavin dance is mostly
characterized as metal core pixie and
pop punk
and i apologize to those of you who are
following along
and you've never heard of either of
these two bands before
but when we look at oops not bad
we go over here to valance and energy
so they file modest mouse somewhere in
the middle across
all of these quadrants you've got
valance over here on the x-axis
and energy on the y-axis um
now dance gavin dance is in the
turbulent and angry category
i can confirm that's completely accurate
modest mouse is right in the middle of
everything between turbulent angry happy
and joyful
sad and depressing chill and peaceful
that one i'm a little bit more on the
fence about but
i'm also not really gonna argue with it
or dispute it
uh there's a timeline here so modest
mouse has been making me
making music since 1972. that doesn't
sound right
1996 sounds sounds more like it
so this kind of information you can plot
balance energy
that kind of thing and how that's
changed over the years
comparison uh
this is more of a distribution kind of
thing
and variety
yeah i don't know where this variety is
uh is exactly coming from
so all that's all that's pretty
interesting stuff
again all this information is coming
from uh spotify
now the uh there's actually no github
repo for this app that i was
able to find uh the
app here all the information here seems
to be coming from
our studio cloud uh the shiny developer
here and i
apologize because i'm completely going
to butcher this name
uh their name is cohen naijin hewish
so good stuff there and it's broken down
to a main
shiny app and an r markdown document
this is inside of a flex dashboard so
very similar to like a shiny dashboard
but with its own sorts of features
definitely a lot more uh html style
stuff within the code
so they've got a main app as well as
their functions
are separated and then they've got one
uh r file which has their packages which
they're loading
so this spotify r package that they're
using
that is basically an r wrapper for
spotify so that's kind of where they're
calling
all this spotify data obviously they're
calling tidyverse i don't know why
they're calling ggplot2 separately but
i mean i can't really blame them because
ggplot2 is uh
obviously a critically important thing
that they're using here
calplot is a really awesome package for
those of you who are unfamiliar with it
it's basically an add-on to ggplot2
but it helps to create more professional
looking graphs from within your ggplot2
framework
high charter is a wrapper for the high
chart
javascript uh interface so that's
a pretty nice thing to use uh viridis
helps you create python matplotlib
style graphs then you've got plotly for
those of you who are unfamiliar with it
uh that's for interactive style graphs
then there's dq
shiny this one i i wasn't familiar with
then i researched it and i think this
one's discontinued from crayon
so that's that's the nuts and bolts that
are going on here
uh again the one that i was actually the
most familiar with
here that i'd like to point out for
those of you who are unfamiliar with
is cow plots because that's really an
awesome package that i don't know how
many are
familiar with but again awesome package
and now the next app is my personal
favorite of all of these
uh and it's a game inside of a shiny app
credit to the author here pedro silva
because this is
absolutely awesome so again it's a game
and like a lot of games it's got an easy
medium and hard
the way i do most games is i do medium
so we're gonna do that here
so you swipe left or right on the card
to start
so it's like tinder but inside of a
shiny app
so swipe right holding the card in one
of the directions we'll show you what
metrics are
affected by uh choosing that decision
so you have various decisions here that
you have to make
and the idea here is you want to
maximize your wealth
the public opinion of you and the
environment
and you also have this karma bar on the
left
now i haven't played around with this
for long enough to know how um
how this exactly influences the game but
you go all the way from an angel to a
devil
and uh apparently yeah that uh that
changes how the
how the game goes for you so we're gonna
play the game for a couple minutes here
and i'm basically going to try and uh do
terribly
so we'll see how it goes news is
spreading that east asia is going to be
hit by a large
food shortage that sounds like way too
much work
oh yeah you can't can't swipe by too
much
oh or maybe you have to swipe by more
never mind election time is almost here
big ag has i guess that's big
agriculture
has offered to deal with the electronic
waste in north america free of charge
sounds like it comes with strings
attached ooh
it's uh very it's very finicky on how
much you need to swipe here
there's news of a huge armed conflict in
the middle east i'm gonna go
huge hell no on that one looks like our
investments in north america are finally
paying it off
we can finally solve that problem oh no
that's that's the good choice so we're
gonna do we don't need to spend it right
now
pollution in central america has reached
a tiny level
has reached a tiny level so i guess the
pollution is starting
uh just send a card or something
uh that sounds sounds like a bad thing
for you to do
a tiny toxic waste site has been
discovered in east asia
not happening this is fun you guys as
you wake up you notice 50 calls from
your assistant
oh see i see the opinion bar at the top
here it's
gone down so this is the equivalent in
this game of me dying
but those 50 calls from your assistant
now what looks like you made some people
really angry
oh no you're probably told you're no
longer in
charge looks like it's over well we had
a good run
and game over we survived for three
weeks
so that was fun and uh one of these days
i'll actually play through this app
and see how long i can actually survive
for real
but the long and the short of it is this
is actually a shiny app which i found
myself forgetting when i was playing
through it
so this one was the one that i was most
impressed by of all of these
so we've got their github repo here
uh one thing to point out is they use
these packages called shiny.grid and
shiny.blank
i personally never heard of them and
they're not available on crayon
so to install these you need to install
them from github
using the devtools package
yeah they've got nice description of
what actually goes on here
uh and they basically make use of
modules and r6 classes here
more on both of these in a minute here
but
they basically break the code down into
six
key modules which are the game manager
data manager
state manager metrics manager map
manager and deck manager
they provide a lot of nice useful
resources here
one of the key
packages that they used here is called
sas uh
the acronym for that escapes me at this
moment
uh if i could find what that is here
then that would be great
uh apparently i can't but uh
it's syntactically awesome stylistic
it's something like that so anyway if we
go into the
source here you get an idea of what's
going on here
oh oops not that the app folder
so with some apps they divided to global
server and ui the global part
is optional but that's typically where
some more of upfront stuff is going to
live in
so again they're using shiny shiny dot
grid shiny dot blank
html tools it's pretty straightforward
tidy r
is an incredibly awesome r package for
going back and forth between
wide and long format or vice versa
leaflet is for making interactive
visualizations
it's really good for making i've used it
one time before for making choropleth
type maps so like visualizing things
inside of an
interactive map r6 is a pretty cool
package
i haven't personally used it that much
now if you've read
hadley wickham's advanced our book he
has a whole chapter on r6 and r6 classes
it's basically a cool package for
writing code
inside of an object oriented type of
framework so you make these r6 classes
and you have methods which are rather
than being totally generalized
these methods are specific to objects
the way
a lot of python code is written they've
got a google sheets package
glue is a useful package occasionally
for
basically evaluating code that's inside
of braces
as actual r code utils is a pretty
generalized r package for
it's not very specific necessarily but
for
just general utilities uh dplyr
jsonlight which converts json objects to
r
objects and vice versa modules
sas and read excel so
sas is another one of those key packages
which they use to put all this together
not something i'd used before or again
even heard of before digging through
this
but again maybe something that you may
be interested in checking out now we've
got app number two
this one's called get discoverer for the
for the ds community and what this does
is within a really nice clean looking ui
compiles repositories and developers and
projects which are trending
you can break this down by a few
different languages of choice
there's r python and javascript as well
as what time frame we want to see
what things are trending so you could do
daily weekly or monthly
let's look monthly and do that search
so some things which are trending here
are swirl courses
for those of you who are unfamiliar
swirl is an awesome resource for
beginners
and even intermediate people i'd say to
learn different functionalities of r
one repo is trending is this awesome r
thing so if we view that that's gonna
take us into github
now this is an incredibly awesome
compilation
of different r resources so there are
packages and tools
um now this is really nicely organized
there's things by 2020 2019 etc
you've got things like data manipulation
graphic displays
and there's all sorts of things like are
you interested in natural language
processing
bayesian optimization honestly this is
really really comprehensive and for
instance if we look at data manipulation
you've got a variety of packages to suit
your individual needs
so deployer is awesome data table data
table is
great for big data reshape2
is good but i like tidr more you get the
idea
going back in here you can look at what
developers are trending
popular projects so this breaks down
popular
uh machine learning projects as well as
deep learning projects
and uh just one thing while it's on my
mind um
this uh awesome r thing here i'll have a
link to that in the
description as well because um it's
there's a reason they call it awesome r
that their their name of themselves is
incredibly accurate in this instance
so yeah um just really just another
really good resource
here for finding other people's machine
learning and deep learning projects and
just seeing how they write code
and learning from it it's just really
really really awesome
and honestly i think with with with this
app and with the code for it too i think
it's a little bit
simpler even than a couple of those apps
that we saw before
and when i say it's simpler that's
actually a good thing i like
simple apps i don't like massively
complex
overwhelming looking apps that just give
me a headache no
this app is nice and clean and simple
and straightforward and easy to use
so credit to the author here raj k stats
if we go into the into the app here
so they break it down like all these
other apps do the packages that they're
using
a few that i never heard of before like
this http
uv allows your r code to listen for and
interact with http and websocket clients
on this library httr required for
uh oauth 2.0 they've got their data
manipulation packages
so the tidy verse of course is the
classic json light just like the last
one
data.table is for your big data
deployer and per are they probably don't
necessarily need to call separately
because those things are part of the
tidy verse once again
but those are for data manipulation and
for functional programming respectively
then they've got shiny shiny themes is
for
just adding more different themes to
your shiny app
again it's for presentation and uh
that kind of purpose shiny js
so interaction with your with javascript
shiny widgets they called shiny js twice
i guess that's a testament to how
awesome shiny js is i guess
uh waiter is for like you may have seen
when i was toggling between different
things inside of the app
there was a little indication that
something was loading
and that's where the waiter is going to
come from
and they've got their custom functions
organized inside of
these various script these scripts
inside of the
scripts folder so if we go back to that
they organize all their functions much
like that last app did which i didn't
really show there
but they organize all their various
functions here so
make tags make cards
i see a lot of html in here so that's
that's always fun to write
make dev cards etc etc you get the idea
and you're able to piece these together
and see how the app all comes together
and then the last app here is called
blog explorer
and this one is really kind of like an
interactive document
more so than anything but you'll really
get the idea as we go through this
just how nice of a deliverable something
like this can be
compared to something like just say
you're putting the exact same kind of
information inside a report
then you give it to your client and then
they read it and then they put it in a
recycling bin and then they never see
that information again
so this is all about 10 plus years of
our blogs so it's a variety of just
summary information on
just blogging that's been done on an r
over the last 10 years
so we can hit the learn more button and
go down the data that's coming in here
comes across 39 978 different articles
written by 2199 different authors
that's about uh i had to count the
digits there in my head by 5.5 million
words which is the equivalent of 18 000
pages of a book
over time each one of these bars
represents a month
and i'm looking at the 2011 time frame
here because that's kind of the advent
time of data science and you see
actually over time the amount of blogs
that are written each month on
r seems relatively flat
but over time the number of non-stop
words per blog has actually increased
or appears to be anyway now that's
pretty interesting because i feel like
even in the data science community
our attention span just seems to be
getting smaller and smaller every year
i guess you blame social media for that
most people are writing blogs on
monday so that's that's interesting i
guess
yeah i mean whatever your flavor of
entertainment is and you got to get
through your mondays somehow
i guess that's the idea published on
monday so that's when your audience is
reading
uh and the number of monthly authors
appeared to hit a peak around 2018. that
kind of corresponds to when
r was really hitting its top popularity
and that seems to be diminishing over
time
and then as we go down here we've got a
network analysis
so you can um
isolate these things and kind of zoom in
so if we look at variable that's related
to things like
correlation analysis value
factor density that kind of thing
bayesian i mean unsurprisingly that's
related to things like alpha
beta posterior prior model
nothing too surprising there
so we can dig through uh their github
repository a little bit
credit to the uh developer nz stefan
global is typically where they uh
illustrate what packages they're using
so a lot less going on in this one
surprisingly
they've got the classic shiny deployer
tidy r
glue is where all the web scraping um
the functionalities for that kind of
thing are coming from
and then there are e-charts for r and
viz network
those are again uh packages for creating
uh interactive visualizations this
network is obviously for the network
visualization kind of thing
and again it's for this interactive
javascript based sort of visualization
that you see here
and again i mean this one is probably
not as complex as that third one is
but they've got their modules and they
just break down all
where all the the functionality is
coming from
so hopefully as i've gone along through
these apps you get an idea of how
powerful
shiny is and all the things that you can
do with it
and that goes for those of you who maybe
you're brand new to r
or you're a beginner or intermediate
with r but you've never used shiny
before
shiny you can do virtually anything with
so hopefully even for those of you who
you're intermediate to advanced with r
i guarantee you you saw some things here
with some of these shiny apps that
you've never done before with your own
apps
so maybe you got some inspiration to try
some new things and push your own shiny
developer skills to the next level
so thanks all of you for watching this
video if you enjoyed it
leave a comment down below and let me
know which which of these apps
is your personal favorite and maybe let
me know if there are any
libraries that you saw along the way
here that you never heard about
because certainly several of these i
never heard of myself
then i'll see all of you in the not so
distant future
until then richard on data